make your family proud
it's time to meet the madrigal family
and more many of the performers dove
into acting for the very first time with
this movie and tons of them recorded in
isolation from all over the world we're
checking out 12 of the performers behind
the voices of encanto
one of the amazing madrigals i'm the
voice of mirabelle from walt disney
animation studios
stephanie beatrice blows her performance
out of the water doing her colombian
father proud i'm part of the amazing
madrial the actress has been on a roll
from playing rosa diaz in brooklyn
nine-nine to countless other projects
she's been taking on including plenty of
time in the booth recording voices for
bob's burgers she did have her fair
share of flubs in the booth for this one
though let's do it again please thank
you a lifelong lover of disney taking on
this role was a literal dream come true
i will save the miracle
now she can help inspire other people to
believe that anything is possible i'm
sure there's behind-the-scenes footage
to show how much fun i was having
definitely yes
even though they worked together from a
distance stephanie's performance still
got lin-manuel miranda right in the
feels i don't know i hope i did it
justice oh no worries about that anyone
that sees the movie knows that she
absolutely did i found his last vision
the family's in trouble the magic is
dying the house is breaking luis's gift
is fading and i think it's all because
of
me
make way abuela is coming through disney
is an american company but that didn't
mean maria cecilia botero had to leave
colombia to do one of their movies with
the pandemic happening over the course
of recording the actress stayed in her
home country working with the creative
team on zoom the miracle
eat with them
blessed eat with her
[Music]
they may never have shared the room
together but that didn't stop potero
from having an amazing collaboration
with the team even when she thought she
was flubbing she was nailing it i'm
talking too fast
no that's not great we know we don't
talk about bruno but we gotta talk about
bruno john leguizamo is one of the
busiest actors around but a packed
schedule wasn't going to stop him from
making room for encanto after all i made
the sparkle his charm is like no other
the performance that comes through his
character on screen really makes an
impact and from the looks of the booth
footage he didn't hold back a thing to
make the candle break you have to
embrace her embrace
any chance of some bruno shorts coming
at us in the future disney hey if you
save the encounter come visit need a
sweet voice encanto has you covered
valderrama is no stranger to voice over
or to disney he played gaxton and onward
and is the manny of handy manny you must
be very excited he also happens to have
been the face behind fez in that 70s
show this role meant the world to him
especially because his own mother is
colombian this part was all heart she's
right i'm more
on screen or behind the mic this actress
works it from jane the virgin to
countless spanish television shows and
movies the colombian actress has made
waves in the industry and really made
her mark in the disney world as julieta
what i think
is that today was very hard for you
celebrating the premiere was super
special since she was one of the many
actors who recorded from their homes
never actually meeting everyone in
person
so so happy because it's the first time
that we meet we didn't really
get to know each other
number six
she goes by dolores in encanto but she
is also known as the reggaeton princess
she didn't get one while she's a
successful singer this is her first time
diving into the acting business i just
felt like a tiger like i seized the
moment luckily it happened because when
she first sent in her audition tape it
went straight to spam the next morning
we had we hadn't heard back and i was
like okay maybe we should write
something and then everything was sorted
but then tragedy struck when arasa found
herself unable to move struggling with
some side effects from having kovid19
but then she got word that disney wanted
her to play dolores
and the day she finally got to get to
work well there was no holding back i
was like all right like give it to me
and then i just let it rip in one take
and he was like we're done and i was
like yes
we have a feeling this won't be her last
voiceover role
that's like the cherry on top of a dream
hair toss check her nails isabella's
ready from jane the virgin to orange is
the new black guerrero never fails to
show just how wide her range is she was
embodying every single part of isabella
while recording her dialogue at the
booth when she got her chance to sing
well she was just a little excited about
it been like waking up with the song and
going to sleep with it even when she
wasn't performing the songs she just
couldn't stay away from bringing those
musical vibes making the movie that much
better
[Music]
i don't know if you wanted me to sing
one of the highlights for the american
colombian actress was of course getting
to work with lin-manuel miranda even if
it was via screen always make those
questions into questions
they didn't need to be together to bring
the magic
i just made something unexpected number
eight
she's feisty and she's fierce she's
luisa with the super strength encounter
marked the american actress's very first
voiceover role while she recorded the
whole thing remotely during the pandemic
she did get to spend some time in person
with the creative team off the bat i
actually had the incredible opportunity
to audition in person in la right before
the pandemic hit which was pretty wild
her performance made luisa a total
standout in the movie especially that
glorious song of hers here's hoping
we'll be hearing a lot more about this
fab actress soon sweet
thank y'all that was good
if you've ever been to colombia you've
probably heard about this guy not just
felix of the madrigals but moro castillo
as well since he's an extremely
successful and popular singer and actor
and trombonist talk about being
multi-talented he brought all the good
vibes to the booth
it was a celebration during the making
and the launch especially after spending
a very long time recording everything to
get it just right uh we are working from
uh
for like a year maybe maybe a year
make way we've got a star coming through
young as he may look juan castano has
already been working for over a decade
making a name for himself on screen and
hit shows like tales of the city and
what if he really made his first voice
overall count in encanto stealing every
scene he's in and very obviously having
a blast in that booth as gift ceremony
was a bummer
what fun is bringing the 60th animated
disney movie to life without some joking
around in laughter
look no further maluma shot to fame as a
singer with that oh so sweet voice of
his and the way he feels about the music
of his country well it just makes us
adore him even more colombian music is
special because we do it with our heart
you know we do it with love considering
how much fun he had and how much magic
he brings to the movie we wouldn't be
surprised if he voices some more
characters soon
she's a legend no big deal rose portillo
has been acting since the 1970s
starring in countless tv shows and films
over the years she gained a whole new
group of fans from her performance as
senora gusman that there weren't
problems with the monthly gun magic
this was one stellar time making the
majority of the film during a pandemic
is no small feat either but it didn't
take away from the magic at all i can't
just talk about myself i'm only part of
the amazing my videos a lot goes into
making an animated film but usually it
isn't all done from home we're going to
take you behind the scenes of encanto to
see just how the amazing magical world
was created comparing early shots to
their finished product let's go talk
about bruno
we don't talk about bruno we don't talk
about bruno the best work trip ever the
crew actually traveled to colombia for
their research they took inspiration
from multiple locations but specifically
the kokora valley one of the most
beautiful places that bruno actor john
leguizamo has ever been to and naturally
it became the inspiration for the home
of the amazing madrigals we knew this is
where the home of the magical girl
should be we mean this quite literally
a lot of layers go into bringing a scene
to life here's just a few of the fun
ones like this one with the block people
did you realize they were making an m
one animator who designed the block shot
was working from home
so he also found himself using his bed
sheets as a reference for the skirt
motions and we're not sure why some of
these children have white eyebrows but
the blocky movement reminds us of when a
video game character freezes and they
just slide across the screen motionless
and the crowds are just as quirky in
their early stages they're just a little
bit creepy to watch this way too if you
ask us
probably the most visually complex movie
we've ever made the best animators are
the best observers very early on the
discussion about what this story had to
be was centered around family this movie
it's about family and your role within
your family the fate of the family it's
not up to her it's up to you
the sister that carries the world on her
shoulders the outcasted uncle we can all
relate to the madrigals in some way and
part of this is because the writers
really drew from experiences with their
own families to get the movements just
right when you see the details in abuela
know that the animator was studying his
mom when family was on the table they
landed on colombia as the perfect place
for their story because colombia is an
intersecting country of latinx people we
did everything there we you know we went
to lots of cities and lots of towns in
the more rural areas we're actually
going to take a look at all the dance
sequences we could find were you
wondering how they got that incredible
skirt work happening imagine how hard it
would have been for the animators to
block this scene if they didn't have a
reference we really shouldn't talk about
this
the choreographer jamal specifically
asked for there to be latinx dancers as
many colombian and latinx people that
can accurately represent the movement
it's actually pretty incredible to watch
how the choreography was incorporated
into the final scenes part of it didn't
end up being used at all so it's a
special look at what could have been and
how picky and choosy you need to be with
the shots in order to get the story
across jamal sims and kai and the
skeleton dancers really brought the song
we don't talk about bruno to life the
actors would do the whole dance in one
take it would be filmed twice once in
skirts and once in pants so they could
get the flow of the skirts but also so
they could get hip movement and not have
it be obscured all you had to do was
just let it take you see if you can spot
any of the characters based on the
dancer's moves alone you can really see
the light-footedness of the dancer
portraying dolores in the scene and
there's so many people that are going to
be influenced by this film not just by
the story you're telling by the
inclusion of the diversity within it an
unlikely group of people sharing
something in common did you know that
animators and dancers share a similar
language and that language is a nonsense
they would speak via the sound of the
rhythm but not necessarily putting the
technical words to it bam bam
communication among different mediums
finds a way we guess it makes sense they
communicate in a similar way they both
work with bodies after all just in
different contexts musical theater has
this incredible tradition of telling
story through song
you can do a lot apparently
you can really feel the larger than life
characters and the joy just flowing out
of the dancers in this piece cartoons
often do things like defy the laws of
gravity so we were a bit surprised to
see just how well they captured the
character performance
it's just an incredible feeling you know
incredible sense of accomplishment
whoever's idea it was to hire lin-manuel
miranda is a genius
the music legend most notably known for
the broadway musical hamilton before
this was brought on board to write the
music for the movie he was one of the
crew who traveled to colombia to immerse
himself in the culture and get
acquainted with the very specific sound
of the music it isn't common for a
disney movie to be written in 3-4 time
miranda said but this movie was an
exception given that time signature is
incredibly important to colombian rhythm
working on a song with 12 very original
and different actors it inspired miranda
to find the pulse of each character and
connect them with different kinds of
colombian music miranda also recorded
himself singing every character's part
for we don't talk about bruno and
probably all of the other music too he
finds it the easiest way to get his
intention across here's hoping disney
one day releases a full album that would
be amazing i just said for the next one
can i just please be there from the
beginning i want to be as involved as i
can be this is probably the biggest
project ever done from home
all of the acting and all of the
coaching actually happened over zoom and
the actors worked out of their own home
studios stephanie beatrice who plays
mirabelle admitted that she didn't find
the process all that strange because
voice acting is usually pretty isolated
anyways i'm part of the amazing madrigal
she's actually found herself closer to
the director because he was right there
on zoom rather than behind a glass panel
lin-manuel was a huge cheerleader for
the actors he's also incredibly patient
which is good for nervous singers it was
actually adasa's idea to make dolores
sing her lines an octave lower just
above a whisper in the song we don't
talk about bruno that's just one element
that all of that character development
brought to the table personalization
i just felt like a tiger like i seized
the moment
imagine how much has to be in place
before the animators can even start
it's always so cool to look back at the
concept art because it ranges so wildly
in character design and costume you can
see how the early art informs the final
choices but also why some things were
cut like mirabelle was designed to be
wearing heels at one point just imagine
how much that would affect her movement
in the movie taking out those high heels
also would have knocked her down a peg
as high heels can present as very
confident something that she's not from
the start
hopefully bring my best to
mirabelle casa casa madrigal casita for
short the one limitation the crew were
working with designing the gorgeous
madrigal home was that they wanted the
house to be alive but they didn't want
it to bend to the elements in order to
move that choice really made this living
house distinct from other living houses
and yes there are more remember a movie
called monster house that's just the
first to come to mind the house
expresses most of its personality
through its tile flipping and window
panes they went through a lot of concept
art to get the house just right which is
fair it's as much a character as the
rest of the family the whole movie could
essentially take place in this house but
it was
limitless of what it could be
we're about to start nitpicking in a
good way did you see how every single
stitch in mirabelle's capybara patch is
so detailed it's absolutely incredible
how far animation has come even in the
past decade colombian folklore and
personality hints were included in every
one of their outfits even mirabelle's
shoes are intricately detailed but did
you notice the outfits were all color
coded based on which part of the family
tree you are that was the idea of the
costume designer in order to help the
audience keep the confusing family tree
straight
so there's a lot to be impressed about
and a lot to laugh at what is so
mind-blowing about encanto is that the
first time a lot of the cast and crew
ever met each other in person was
actually at the premiere of the movie do
you think the premiere was awkward for
the cast who'd only ever worked on zoom
or do you think they were having a party
to work with everybody i think requires
especially for this movie a lot of
different points of view encanto has
plenty of deleted scenes that make a
whole lot of sense and yet contain a
whole lot of nonsense at the same time
and speaking of nonsense we're also
checking out the bloopers
i just changed the whole movie for you
i didn't know i could do that
interesting
we honestly have no idea what to make of
this scene
in a very rapunzelesque moment isabella
sneaks out her window and goes into the
woods mirabelle thinks she's been
attacked by a wild animal but as it
turns out it's just a man dressed like a
big cat to scare off animals
most predators hunt by smell which is
why i covered it in the urine of several
animals and then isabella makes out with
the costumed man named bobo in front of
her sister
you saw nothing i wish i saw nothing
this scene honestly just seems like a
prank but the two were planning to run
away together presumably because of all
the pressure from abuela we're glad this
scene was cut as funny as it is removing
it made her plotline distinct from
dolores's
i couldn't really put words to or a
feeling to
what i saw
to love it all is to love entirely
this was originally
nearly the end of the movie when
mirabelle
devastated has left the family
originally mirabelle was going to run
much further than the river she was
going to run all the way back to the
city her abuela ran away from where she
would encounter the new world abuela
sits out on her own
she comes across a mural that says to
love it all is to love entirely she
finds mirabelle sitting on a bench with
nowhere to go and no idea what to do it
sounds like in this version julieta was
injured pretty bad too i couldn't bear
the thought of losing anyone else
the whole thing seemed a bit sad but we
love the idea of returning to where you
came from it's never the same after you
leave and even if it is it doesn't evoke
the same feelings within you well we
absolutely loved the movie it feels like
we waited the entire movie for a big
journey that never got past the river
keeping the family away from modern day
advancements was probably a good call
what do you think
i think that that's a testament to our
directors and what they're able to do
we wonder if isabella could bring
anything else to life or if it was just
potatoes you heard that right similar to
elsa with olaf isabella brought a little
cluster of potatoes to life we're unsure
what their use would have been in the
movie but they sure are cute they were
cut very early in the process for the
princess of perfection you'd expect
living flowers like in alice in
wonderland not potato people but who are
we kidding potatoes are perfection why
is it that isabella had the weirdest
cutscenes
allowed myself to have this opportunity
you know it's not easy to be here and to
get here honestly you could never
convince us that mopping is more fun
than talking to jaguars mirabelle gets
stuck cleaning the house with her
non-magical dad and uncle hey forget out
there this job in here is the most
special we get a little peek of dolores
room but at this point in the story
she's the character who healed with food
not the mom
and peppa doesn't control the weather
she has indestructible powers still
alive
[Music]
we kind of actually love the development
of the fathers in this scene because
we've been wondering how it would feel
to be these two married into a family of
magical people their total devotion is
heartwarming and we learned that bruno
only got his name because lin-manuel
miranda came up with the lyrics to we
don't talk about bruno on the spot yeah
it was amazing
so his original name oscar was dropped
oh also his room wasn't a sandy cave at
first either his room turned all rotten
gross and sand doesn't rot so we just
put two and two together
he just
created a safe space for me to be as
weird as possible honestly we would have
loved to see this scene in the movie
mirabelle and antonio were going to go
on a jungle trip together to get into
bruno's room as the original entrance
was blocked we felt antonio pretty much
got snuffed out of the movie after he
got his powers this deleted scene shows
us exactly why we feel this way but what
we love about the cutscene is it gave us
great perspective into how the rooms
work i think you have like
the coolest room
however it created a much more
mysterious feel to go through the sand
rather than take a different route
through antonio's room
but we are much happier with the way
they set up luis's song in the end catch
her before she cracks not after and also
mirabelle's prying added way more to the
stakes of the scene eventually i'm gonna
sing you a song right here yeah that's
right luis has a softie under the
surface
her room never wound up in the movie but
that's okay because we definitely got
hints of it with the unicorn donkeys
don't believe us the concept art from
luisa's room showed that she might have
had a secret door to escape the pressure
of her family
while the obvious choice for a room was
a gym or one that was made purely out of
stone it's that secret gateway that led
to a theme park that really piques our
interest
everybody needs an escape sometimes
right
oh you're gonna make me drop a donkey
they're playing a game of musical chairs
with superpowers the characters powers
bounced around the family a lot before
they landed on who worked best with what
peppa and a firepowered character named
fuega merged with each other there were
twins named amelia and sophia amelia had
an aura that made everyone fall in love
with her but her sister sophia had an
aura that repulsed everyone given we
already have bruno and mirabelle who
feel unappreciated it's probably good
they didn't have a third outcast you see
you're missing the point
the fate of the family it's not up to
her it's up to you
there was also a guy whose personality
may have merged with camilo that of the
pool playing trickster princessa has
concept art similar to that of isabella
so she didn't make it past the cutting
room floor there was also a character
named zoe who could speak with
technology but when she was sleeping
that technology didn't like to do its
job
miranda may have been an earlier version
of antonio as she seems to be holding a
rabbit she may have been an early
concept of mirabelle's mother giving
julieta the power of healing through
food allowed for she and her daughter to
bond in a special way i wish you could
see yourself the way i do
you are perfect
just like this
yes the madrigal family is much
different in concept than what we saw on
screen just goes to show how hard they
worked at giving all of the characters a
power that reflects their place in the
family but also their place in the
storytelling
no two characters are alike in any way
we were saved
because of you
and it's time for some bloopers
we're so used to stephanie beatrice
playing rosa we can't get over how
adorably charming she is we were so
distracted by that we forgot to tell you
she's not saying the line as scripted
when i saved the miracle when i saved
the miracle when i saved the miracle
after i saved the miracle
first gift ceremonies are so magical you
forget what to say first gifts first
first gifts ceremony
set uh ceremony ceremony ceremony it's
nice to see that the actress behind
abuela can get a little silly
miracle
eat with them
blessed to eat with
the
her
blessed each with a magic gift to help
us
proof that voice acting is really acting
and maybe the biggest challenge since
you're playing pretend all by yourself
i make the speckle yeah it's it's hard
to say
i made the sparkle make the sparkle you
made how did he do that if bathrooms had
better soundproofing voice-over actors
would probably record from the toilet no
joke they are constantly drinking water
you guys need to go the restroom i know
that as well i've been going to the
bathroom this whole time that feel when
your father doesn't know how to say your
name am i saying mirabelle or mirabelle
what am i saying i forgot am i fighting
or hugging
help us out is this an acting choice or
is he warming up his face muscles to
make the candle break you have
and embrace and embrace
why so intense
am i doing it coming uh
the answer is
no they weren't expecting you to sing
but
we liked it anyway please don't clap
thank you oh it's nothing
[Music]
i don't know if you wanted me to sing he
must have jinxed himself
into the mic that would be an
interesting way of recording wouldn't it
what does it mean
is it why you came back or
we understand why these scenes didn't
make the final cut introduced audiences
to this character who just so happens to
be who he is but it was nice to get a
glimpse into how the magic rooms work
you got this
it takes an army of animators to bring
us our favorite movies so it's no
surprise that some mistakes happen and
we forgive the animators because it
makes it more fun for us the audience to
comb through and find them we're
sleuthing out the mistakes in disney's
latest animated movies starting off with
the charming encanto
number one if we remember correctly
dolores isn't the shapeshifter during
the song we don't talk about bruno you
may recall this little scene of the
family dancing around mirabelle but did
you notice how the woman holding the
dead fish dances off screen and suddenly
dolores is in her place we definitely
think this one was a mistake because the
fish woman is the only outsider in this
scene and then just disappears midway
through if it by chance wasn't a mistake
it's at the very least quite an odd
artistic choice don't you think
we say nothing number two the totally
normal box of fun has more magical
powers than anybody's letting on
the not so special special that
mirabelle has handed has the maracas
facing her which would make for a super
awkward way to hold a basket full of
thingamabobs but in the next shot the
basket appears flipped around now the
maracas are facing away from her
delivery
i gave you the special number three
luisa's the strong one not the
teleporting one the position of luisa
changes in this scene she's obviously
behind camilo in one shot and in the
next is very much in front hey maybe
she's actually that shape-shifting kid
in disguise
wait no camilo is the shape-shifting kid
sorry it's hard to keep them all
straight maybe we need to re-listen to
that song
number four babies are escape artists in
raya and the last dragon we don't
remember noi having the power of super
speed but somehow she managed to get
from on top of tuk-tuk to down beside
tong for when he picks her up and we
seriously doubt she made a sudden
decision to jump we'll forgive the
animators it's definitely a tender
moment for noi and tong and we would
rather have it than not have it we bet
the animators noticed it and chose not
to change it it probably would have been
a huge pain to reanimate noi on the
ground the entire scene leading up to
the moment noi
it's her name number five there's
nothing sadder than your ice cream
suddenly disappearing on you unless of
course you'd already dropped it on the
ground then who cares maybe a seagull
snuck away with it but there's no
remnants of it ever existing so we're
guessing not
maybe i said it wrong
number six do the fish people turn into
fish on the insides when they drink
water we're just wondering this
animation concern is more a question of
continuity than an animating mistake per
se how do the characters immediately
turn human upon jumping out of the water
while still wet and in other shots the
boys struggle to turn back to being
human and it takes forever for them to
dry off do we really care
no not at all because the shots of luca
and alberto jumping out of the water are
fantastic and the moments of almost
being caught are obviously very
important for the stakes of the movie
and for our laughs
number seven maybe the canvases are
imbued with the same magic as maui's
tattoos the canvas beside the maui
canvas is a three-headed monster in one
shot but once the chief comes in and is
tackled by children it completely
changes the next time we see it and now
depicts an island we don't think our
theory behind these canvases is
completely impossible what do you think
simple mistake there are no monsters
number eight perhaps it's tongue works
like window blinders those things are a
pain the water monster has moana almost
entirely in his mouth in one shot and
the next she's still completely out of
it you really can't blame this one on
the angle it's almost like the magic of
cinema is what saved her you're no one
pharaoh
no one
[Music]
number nine if only our hair could be
this cooperative for selfies
grandma tala's hair was over her right
shoulder in one shot and the very next
draped across her back
number 10 only encanto has these thank
you at the end of the movie when miguel
finally comes back to the land of the
living ernesto's tomb is wide open
allowing him to leave but the doors were
closed and locked earlier in the movie
and the guitar is still left in the
exact same position so nobody has been
inside since
what are you doing with them
number eleven if they'd vanished for
more than just a shot that would really
help our heroes along the security
guards disappear in a shot with mama
emelda and ernesto de la cruz did you
catch that although this doesn't feel so
much like a continuity error but more
the creators just wanting to set up a
very distinctive and beautiful shot with
the bright colors framing our characters
if the security guards were in the
background of the shot we feel like it
would just take away from the final
product what do you think
number 12. reindeers are stealthier than
people there's actually a bunch of
continuity errors in frozen two we
imagine it comes with the territory of
sequels here's the first of several sven
in the matter of a couple seconds
managed to completely sneak out a frame
while the gang was chatting is nobody
watching the reindeer do we really trust
him to be left to his own devices
that was magic
did you see that of course i saw it
number 13. how far back did they really
get bounced it didn't seem like more
than a couple of feet okay kristoff just
attempted to enter the spooky mist and
got nowhere so they're literally right
there at the wall but when elsa touches
the mist and it disperses we get this
big wide shot of the mist anna and elsa
and suddenly kristoff is out of frame
and has to walk like 20 feet to catch up
with them how does that make sense we do
this together okay
number 14 which side of the sword is
more dangerous anna is gripping the
icicle sword as it faces towards her
head which seems just slightly more
dangerous than running with scissors
perhaps the animator who did the next
shot realized this and didn't want her
to be impaled and so reversed the sword
or maybe the logic they used to justify
it is that in the matter of seconds the
icicles melted and then refroze on the
other side would you buy that with us
the movie is playing with the elements
so it's always a possibility
number 15 to the left to the left anna
appears on the wrong side of elsa in
this shot where the camera sneaks up
from behind maybe anna was just playing
a game where she tapped on elsa's
shoulder and then snuck around her we
know it you know it not a mistake just a
prank right okay fine the camera's
flipped the characters are flipped it's
gotta be hard to do some mental math for
who goes where we still hold our fingers
up to figure out which way is left so
who are we to judge
uh what's happening that's it number 16.
it would be weird if the dad was legs
and just like an eighth of his stomach
right it's debatable if this is really a
mistake or not but it is strange we get
a pretty good idea of what the dad's
shirt looks like as he's brought back to
life but once he stumbles into the
laundry he comes back out just with
glowing pants maybe it was some sort of
snapback motion either way we didn't see
it so we're calling it a mistake
hi
dad number 17 markers like legos appear
out of nowhere in this shot it isn't
here in the next it is remember those
crayola pipsqueak markers with the fun
names like small potatoes we bet it was
that kind they were the funnest and we
bet this one is called the little boy
blue think about it it makes total sense
we've got the little boy blue elf and
the man on the moon distant father
father who's passed away who's smart we
are
number 18 clean up on aisle 2.
disappearing soda isn't exactly as sad
as disappearing ice cream but still sad
nonetheless it's been dropped just
outside the doorway in this shot but
once the bikes are knocked over you can
clearly see to the side that the soda is
gone perhaps another magical creature
handled the mess swiftly but we
seriously doubt it this one's lucky
number 19. if not the devil maybe
barley's got some spider-man powers
that's that's a joke because tom holland
voices ian okay
um
sure sorry bad joke should have made a
star-lord one instead barley's on top of
the passenger seat and then suddenly is
on ian's shoulder brother no brother
brother no brother the elf on his
shoulder appears as fast as the devils
and angels perhaps if no spidey powers
were being used there was a poof we just
didn't get to see
number 20 maybe joe's real purpose is to
be a magician the things in joe
gardner's hands switch around from one
shot to the next originally the pizza
crust is on the right in one shot and in
the next the bagel and spool of thread
suddenly made their way to the right wow
that's uh great
we're quick to assume all of these
moments are mistakes that the animators
completely missed but the truth is
animators only have so much time to
finish a shot and sometimes perhaps
continuity must be sacrificed in order
to give us more easter eggs or other
special moments like that moment where
maui kicks a rock
that would have been a character choice
made by that animator who probably
didn't do the shot before it like seven
seconds of animation is something like
168 frames imagine painting that many
paintings yeah but what about bruno i
mean we don't talk about bruno we don't
talk about bruno and kanto is all magic
and mystery from cut scenes and
characters to covid messing with the
status quo this movie endured a lot of
changes to the script and creation
process in order to get made
let's take a look
let's dig a little deeper into what
makes the music of encanto sing a trope
as old as time
in one plotline of the movie due to
mirabelle's mistakes something bad
happened to mirabelle's mom julieta
i couldn't do it
and now my mom
is we have our theories as most of the
disney princesses are motherless for
whatever reason so we are really glad
they didn't go this route
such a huge corporation like disney
leaves so much room for improv stephanie
beatriz improvised a ton all throughout
encanto not just the comedy bits but the
darker things like the conversations
with abuela too one line that 100 came
from her own brain was in bruno's room
after she was abandoned by pico the
toucan nope he flew away immediately
but the improv king had to be actor
comedian john leguizamo who played bruno
improvising the entire rat telenovela
their love could never be
a little lesson from casita watch where
you pee
there's an after credit scene where
antonio's capybara named chipsy tries to
take a leak on casita but the home
strikes back this scene was cut because
the creators decided it wasn't the note
they wanted to end the movie on but
personally we think it's the perfect
finale what do you think
we don't talk about emo mo mo mo bruno's
name was oscar before it was bruno when
the team decided to change the name in
order to legally protect themselves
given there are a lot of oscar madrigals
in colombia they gave lin-manuel miranda
the options of arlo anko andre imo bruno
or marco he picked bruno and rolled with
it and came up with the opening of we
don't talk about bruno almost instantly
we don't talk about emo just doesn't hit
the same way we had to create this
really quirky offbeat guy
who was who had bad social skills
basically and he has to hide away
isabella wasn't always your cliche
disney princess gone rogue just a couple
drafts of isabella included her as a
punk rocker and one where she runs away
with her city-slicking animal
urine-wearing boyfriend booboo we highly
recommend you check out the cut scene
called isabella goes into the woods it's
so weird we still struggle to believe
this was a genuine plot at one point
booboo marquez
are you all right
i am fine miami isabella could even
bring vegetables to life like elsa and
olaf at one point specifically potato
people we aren't sure if it was all
vegetables so there was a little family
of potato people living with her between
booboo and potatoes we're a little
surprised her character's journey became
what it did
is our only chance to be free
we could use a whole other song about
all of the cut characters so many
characters were cut or changed
drastically from one draft to the next a
cut character named zoe could
communicate with machines there were two
twins who gave off the auras of
compulsion and repulsion there was
originally a moody fire character named
fuega which we can see being the
inspiration for peppa peppa's power was
changed from indestructible to weather
controlling because she was too similar
to luisa and controlling the weather
used to be julieta's power
in an earlier draft the default skin
camilo's hanging around in wasn't
actually his true form so when the magic
died he lost his power and nobody
recognized him which is super sad this
was eventually cut because it took too
much attention off of yerebel
yeah i like did the whole thing
so like it's extremely special to me the
show-stopping number got summarized in
half the time
the song all of you was originally going
to be seven minutes long it's already a
fantastical song that combines surface
pressure what else can i do and we don't
talk about bruno a very broadway thing
to do but originally it also contained
more of the villagers and abuela
offering some clarity on why she did
what she did singing i was so afraid of
losing what we've made focused on the
dark instead of letting in the light i
lost your father far too soon i couldn't
bear to lose you too the miracle is not
some magic we forgot the miracle is you
not some gift just you we don't need any
excuses abuela kidding but we feel like
her heart to heart at the river with
mirabelle was enough this cut is totally
understandable i thought we would have a
different life
i thought
i would be a different woman
stephanie beatriz was waiting on a
miracle much larger than mirabelle's she
was over nine months pregnant when she
recorded the song waiting on a miracle
and she had the baby just 48 hours later
in the booth she had to do whatever she
had to do to be able to get those high
notes out which generally included
putting her hands over her head and she
even did a bunch of squats
what can she say except you're welcome
for her audition stephanie beatrice
originally had to sing that fun catchy
tune from moana sung by dwayne the rock
johnson the best part was that somebody
animated it well let me say let me say
you're welcome
fight fight fight
you know what this was probably not an
entirely appropriate thing for a family
movie but in an earlier version of the
film isabella and mirabelle actually got
into a physical fight and apparently
it was hilarious we're sad we missed it
but it's probably for the best
this budget isn't for belly button
piercings and kanto seriously had a
belly button budget dedicated solely to
having the one minor character's gut pop
on screen giving side characters belly
buttons is a big deal they're rarely
ever animated on minor characters unless
it's maybe a beach scene but the crew
totally found the work worth it to give
the donkey delivery guy his gut
by the way that was his name in the
script for a while
oh and antonio good luck last gift
ceremony was a bummer while we're on the
topic of names the woman with the dead
fish her name was senora pes muerto
which translates to mrs deadfish we
guess naming minor characters based on
their minor roles makes a lot of sense
for keeping them all organized and it's
also much nicer than calling them
background number one and background
number two but in this instance maybe
they should have stuck with that
just act normal no one has to know
it takes a village to create a character
who's to say the voice actors are the
only ones acting animators are also
actors and during a time of covid their
reference videos were done in their
houses we appreciate the dude who went
to the extent of using his bed sheets as
skirt references the residuals must be
nice when you're trilingual angisa peda
who plays julieta is the only actor to
voice her character in three different
languages
english spanish and italian i healed
your hand
with my love for my daughter the crew
was seriously racing against the clock
to finish encanto they were working on
the movie basically up until the moment
it had its premiere they technically
wrapped production a month before its
release but they were still making minor
adjustments after that when we think of
the best apology songs we instantly
think taylor swift not lin-manuel
miranda miranda based the song surface
pressure on his sister it's his love
letter and his apology to her as she was
the eldest sister in the family and
definitely felt some of that pressure
miranda's mouth clicks he recorded for
the scratch track made it into surface
pressure too it's such a simple and nice
little touch we get the song called
surface pressure and it was about how
she's very cool on the surface and
there's nothing she can handle turns out
the madrigal casita is full of secrets
it took some work for the team to come
up with what they wanted luisa's room to
look like they had a dull stone room to
represent her strength which ended up
lending itself to bruno's room and it
was set on a beach at one point but the
best idea was that she had a secret room
inside of her room that was an amusement
park to de-stress a bit we kind of feel
bad for mirabelle though who didn't even
get a single magic room let alone two
nope hold on
while it's cool to know you can do voice
acting from home
the cast all had to record in their
homes while they got most of the
characters sounding the same we're
pretty sure we caught a couple lines
where isabella sounds like she's in a
different room if you weren't always
trying too hard you wouldn't be in the
way actually lisa did you hear it or are
we paranoid now that we think about it
she could have just been leaning into
the mic before kovid whenever possible
voice actors would do ensemble
recordings in an actual studio most of
them didn't even meet until the first
screening how crazy is that see myself
be a part of something so monumental um
just an incredible feeling you know
reverse psychology choreography
choreography is usually done after the
scene layout is complete since the
choreographer was brought in before the
layout's completion it meant the dancers
had more influence over the shots of the
film because the method was so
successful we wonder if the industry
will follow in encanto's footsteps from
now on disney comes with all the perks
stephanie beatriz worked with vocal
coach eric vitro he's incredible he's
really really gifted he's been the coach
to ariana grande camila cabello and sean
mendes to name a few
and konto will forevermore hold a
special place in our hearts it's by far
one of disney's best films in a long
time and if you believe in magic believe
in this two years before stephanie
beatriz was even hired to voice the role
mirabelle's name was beatrice is that
not fate or what are there any other
movie making secrets we should have
included in the video let us know in the
comments and thanks for joining us here
at the things